[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
willkommen zu einem sehr
außergewöhnlichen Mordfall mein Name ist
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer und
wie immer könnt ihr diesen Podcast
kostenlos hören es gibt aber eine Sache
die ihr für uns tun könnt wenn euch
Tatort Deutschland gefällt abonniert uns
und aktiviert die Glocke und hinterlasst
uns gerne eine Bewertung oder schreibt
einen Kommentar damit supportet ihr uns
und wir sind natürlich unendlich dankbar
vielen Dank
[Musik]
wir arbeiten diesmal einen Fall nach der
an sich schon sehr bemerkenswert ist die
Geschichte des Kindermörders Erwin
Hagedorn in der DDR unfassbar in diesem
Fall ist allerdings was nach Aufklärung
der Mordserie geschah
[Musik]
nachdem ich vergeblich den ganzen
Nachmittag nach einem passenden jungen
besucht hatte und zwei Versuche
fehlgeschlagen waren kam mir der Junge
am Abend sehr gelegen und meine
sexuellen Handlungen an ihm durchführen
zu können
ein überführter Mörder musste in der DDR
als Schauspieler in einem Lehrfilm über
die eigenen Taten mitmachen bevor er
hingerichtet wurde während die
Todesstrafe altertümlich daherkommt sind
es die Ermittlungsmethoden nicht an dem
Fall arbeitet einer der ersten Profiler
der DDR außerdem scheut sich die Polizei
in diesem Fall nicht sich Material über
ähnliche Verbrechen aus Westdeutschland
zu besorgen
legen wir also los
im Frühsommer 1969 machen Waldarbeiter
im brandenburgischen Eberswalde eine
Autostunde nordöstlich von Berlin eine
grausige Entdeckung sie finden die
Leiche eines jungen sowie sein Fahrrad
einen Tag später wird in der Nähe ein
weiterer Toter entdeckt ihm wurde die
Kehle durchgeschnitten schnell erklärt
sich dass es sich bei den Kindern um die
beiden neunjährigen Jungen Henry Specht
und Mario Luis handelt sie waren 13 Tage
zuvor vermisst gemeldet worden bereits
am Folgetag erfolgte eine erste größere
Suchaktion durch Polizeikräfte vor Ort
allerdings ohne Ergebnis danach wurden
mit such Ketten ganze Waldstücke
durchkämpft und am 12 juni wurde sogar
mit einer Meldung in der Regionalzeitung
neuer Tag nach den Jungs gesucht
unüblich in der DDR
zuletzt hatte ein Jäger die beiden Jungs
auf Fahrrädern und in Begleitung eines
jungen Mannes gesehen das Verbrechen
erschüttert die verschlafene Gegend auch
die Volkspolizei ist schockiert die
Jungen wurden so stark verstümmelt dass
sich bei einem von ihnen durch die
Verwesung der Kopf vom Rumpf löst
aber die Ermittler finden keine
verwirrbaren Spuren am Tatort es gibt
bis auf die Aussage des Jägers keine
Hinweise und so gerät tatsächlich
erstmal der Jäger ins Visier der Beamten
aber ihm lässt sich nichts nachweisen
die Eberswalder Polizei bittet den
Psychiater hans-check um Hilfe er hatte
vier Jahre zuvor eine Studie über
Sadismus als Form sexueller abnorität
veröffentlicht eigentlich ist es
erstaunlich dass so früh so hochkarätige
Hilfe geholt wurde also ich verstehe die
Berichte über die damalige Zeit so wie
schon bei unserem vorherigen Fall dem
Vampir von Schlesien da waren Verbrechen
im Sozialismus mega problematisch denn
eigentlich arbeitete man ja in der
perfekten Gesellschaft mit glücklichen
Menschen also sollte der Fall so schnell
und vor allem unauffällig wie möglich
gelöst werden der Forscher von der
Charité zieht folgende Schlüssel
der Täter ist ein Sadist der es auf
Kinder abgesehen hat wahrscheinlich
handelt es sich um einen jungen Mann der
noch nicht vorbestraft ist
damit sollte dr Chef chic Recht behalten
aber die Hinweise führen jetzt im Sommer
1969 erstmal zu keinem Durchbruch ende
1970 werden die Ermittlungen vorläufig
eingestellt leider muss erst ein
weiterer Mord passieren bis es
Fortschritte gibt am 9 Oktober berichten
Kinder in Eberswalde ihren Eltern
atemlos dass ihr Freund Ronald von einem
jungen Mann gejagt wurde er sei in den
Wald geflohen und verschwunden
am nächsten Morgen wird aus den
Befürchtungen Gewissheit man findet im
gleichen Waldabschnitt wie zwei Jahre
zuvor den 12-jährigen Ronald Winkler
diesmal gibt es aber Spuren an der Jacke
des Opfers auch Ronald wurde missbraucht
und mit einem Messer verstümmelt nach
dem dritten Mord zeigt die
Polizeipräsenz besonders im Eberswalder
Stadtteil Westend der an den Wald grenzt
hier wird vor jedem Hauseingang ein
Polizist postiert Kinder dürfen das Haus
nur noch in Begleitung eines Elternteils
verlassen jedes Kind muss zur Schule
gebracht und abgeholt werden die
Ermittlungen werden unter Hochdruck
wieder aufgenommen auch Psychiater Dr
hans-check ist wieder mit dabei er
versucht das Täterprofil mit Hilfe des
neuen falls noch zu präzisieren
dafür besorgen ihm Stasi-Agenten auch
Unterlagen zum Fall des Kindermörders
Jürgen Bartsch aus Westdeutschland ja
das ist ein ganz übler Typ der
19-Jährige metzgergeselle Bartsch lockte
in den 60er Jahren in
Nordrhein-Westfalen vier Jungs in einen
Bunker er verging sich an ihnen tötete
und zerstückelte sie er wurde im Juni
1966 gefasst
Bart war von seinen Adoptiveltern bis zu
Beginn der Schulzeit isoliert gehalten
worden mit zehn kam er dann in ein
katholisches Heim wütet also auch in der
DDR ein seelisch verkümmerter junger
Sadist wie in Nordrhein-Westfalen dr
Chef schick rät der Volkspolizei an den
Schulen der Region zu ermitteln er ist
sicher der Täter sucht die Nähe zu
seinen Opfern und muss schon in der
Vergangenheit aufgefallen sein die
Volkspolizisten ziehen durch die Klassen
und fragen
seid ihr schon mal bedrängt oder
belästigt worden ist euch ein junger
Mann aufgefallen der etwas von euch
wollte und schließlich meldet sich
nervös und wieder will ich der
zwölfjährige Andreas K und der der
erzählt eine haarsträubende Geschichte
andreas war mit seiner Mutter im Winter
im Wald um mit seinen holzskieren von
Hügeln runter zu fahren dabei begegnete
ihnen ein junger Mann den Mann vom Sehen
aus der Stadt kannte da die Mutter nach
Hause wollte blieb Andreas mit dem Mann
allein schließlich habe der ihn bedroht
und sexuell missbraucht der Unbekannte
ließ Andreas laufen drohte aber erzähle
niemandem etwas das ist der Durchbruch
Andreas kann sogar beschreiben wo der
namentlich nicht bekannte wohnt
die Polizei bereitet den Zugriff vor und
durch den Blick ins Melderegister weiß
sie jetzt der Mann heißt Erwin Hagedorn
er ist 19 Jahre alt und Kochlehrling in
der Mitropa bahnhofsküche er wird am 12
november 1971 verhaftet und er gesteht
schon in den ersten Vernehmungen alle
drei Morde wie es ausdrücklich heißt tut
er das natürlich ohne das Gewalt
angewendet wird und da ist er der nicht
vorbestrafte sadistische junge Mann der
es auf kleine Jungs abgesehen hat wie
vom Psychiater Dr chefc von der Berliner
Charité vorhergesagt durch stundenlange
Befragungen ergibt sich das Psychogramm
eines gestörten Jugendlichen der
schließlich zum Mörder wird hagedorns
Eltern stellen stets die höchsten
Ansprüche an ihn wegen seines überall
etwas wird er in der Schule frühzeitig
gehänselt
deshalb spielt er lieber mit jüngeren
Kindern und an denen dass er einfach
sein Frust raus und sie
eines Tages bedroht er ein Mädchen sogar
mit einem Messer zu seinen Eigenschaften
gehört auch eine Vorliebe für
Schauspielerei aber nach der Schule
lernt Erwin Koch im Bahnhofsrestaurant
wieder gilt er hier schnell als
Wichtigtuer und Einzelgänger er hantiert
gern theatralisch mit Messern herum
Erwin zimmert sich eine Hütte im Wald
und lockt mehrfach Jungs dort hinein um
sie zu missbrauchen und zu quälen der
zwölfjährige andreas war nur eines von
vielen Opfern
durch die Bedrohung bringt er die Kinder
dazu die Erlebnisse zu verschweigen Lust
am Quälen entwickelt der außerdem wenn
er im Restaurant Fische schlachtet die
Polizei hat einen geständigen Mörder dem
schon bald der Prozess gemacht werden
kann aber die Leitung der Volkspolizei
verstärkt sich in eine verstörende Idee
sie will den Fall Erwin Hagedorn in
einem Lehrfilm für angehende Polizisten
aufarbeiten in der Hauptrolle Hagedorn
selbst und jetzt wird es völlig absurd
denn die Kinder also die potenziellen
Opfer werden von Söhnen von
Polizeibeamten gespielt der Schauspieler
der Wichtigtuer hagelton der macht gerne
mit er läuft in dem Schwarz-Weiß-Film
durch den Wald bedroht die Kinder stürzt
sich auf die Puppen die für die
eigentlichen Mord sind dann genutzt
werden
und er schildert sein furchterregendes
Innenleben ich habe eine bestimmte
Vorstellung welchen jungen ich zu
sexuellen Handlungen nehme
ich diesen jungen dass er seinem Alter
entsprechend eine Größe seine Größe sein
muss dass er
nicht zu mager oder zu dick ist dass er
nach Möglichkeit keine Abstände in Ohren
hat kein Brillenträger ist
das sein ganzes Wesen kindlich ist auch
seine Schilderung der Mordszene ist zum
Gruseln
seit dem Verlassen der Weser hatte ich
ein steifes geht das heißt ich war
sexuell
aufgrund dessen dass ich der Junge
weigerte und meine Aufforderung
nachzukommen starte ich zu
aufgrund dessen dass der Junge versucht
um Hilfe zu schreiben hätte ich ihm noch
seinen Hals durch zu verwickelte ich
aber mein Taschentuch und mein linken
Daumen und drückte ihm die Kehlkopf ein
im Film geht der Mörder auch darauf ein
wie in das Töten der Speisefische
ankippte dieses
Schlachten hatte für mich keine sexuelle
Bedeutung jedoch war es für mich eine
innerliche Genugtuung zuzusehen wie sich
die Karten bzw alle
mit ihren Tode kämpften wobei ich dann
die
alle den Kopf abschlug und ich
bevorzugte besonders alle zu schlachten
Karpfen haben wir allerdings noch
nach den abstechen kein anderes Leben
mehr aber alle und schließlich
beschreibt Hagedorn wie es zum Mord im
Herbst 1971 kam der Fall und die
grausamen Details aus dem Film die
empören den damaligen Regierungschef der
DDR weiter Ulbricht aufs Äußerste er
besteht noch vor dem Prozess darauf dass
Hagedorn hingerichtet wird jede
Möglichkeit einer Begnadigung soll
ausgeschlossen werden wenn ich
überraschend wird deshalb am 15 Mai 1972
das folgende Urteil der Angeklagte wird
wegen mehrfachen vollendeten und
vorbereiteten Mordes teilweise in
parkeinheit mit mehrfacher vollendeter
und versucht der Nötigung zu sexuellen
Handlungen und mehrfachen vollendeten
und versuchten sexuellen Missbrauch von
Kindern von Todesurteilen am 15
September 1972 wird Erwin Hagedorn in
der Justizvollzugsanstalt Leipzig mit
einem Schuss in den Hinterkopf
hingerichtet übrigens gab es die
Todesstrafe in der DDR noch bis 1987
also nur zwei Jahre vor der Wende das
letzte Todesurteil wurde aber am 26 Juni
1981 vollstreckt hingerichtet wurde der
Stasi-Offizier Werner Teske weil er
angeblich für den Westen spioniert haben
sollte das war's für heute danke dass
ihr wieder mit dabei wart und wir freuen
uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal
wieder einschaltet Schnitt und Aufnahme
Toni Heyer Postproduktion weight watch
Studios München das Skript schrieb
Stefan Netzeband bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und eure Toni